all right so i'm on tour right now and
the first thing that i think about
whenever i'm on tour
let's start with what's really essential
perhaps a hug or a compliment from your
father deep in meaningful relationship
and friendships and a larger sense of
self and purpose in this weird thing
called life but for the sake of this
one of my travel essentials
hey gq i'm hussa minhaj
and these are my essentials
this is a travel kit
by freegrace i've watched a lot of these
things the algorithm has had a
disproportionate impact on the things
that i buy and i follow sports instagram
pages and i always see nba players with
the louis vuitton or like the prada dopp
kit and i bought a cheap one from fossil
years ago when i put stuff in it
everything just sloshed around and i
realized you need separators on my
wedding day i walked into
bina's room where she was getting ready
and her cousin
pulled out one of these and i saw all
her makeup
all her supplies and i was like why
don't guys have this so this is it you
get separation of church and state you
have dividers what's really great about
this this is all velcro we can do this
in thirds or we can just make this a
solo pocket you don't seem as impressed
by this design
do you understand how impressive this is
this is the dob kit problem you reach in
oh there's a razor blade like you don't
know what you're grabbing you can hang
it on a wall or when you get to a hotel
you close the bathroom door and boom you
hang it up again i'm a man of the people
a lot of people here nick jonas will be
here and he'll be like oh it's my patek
philippe no no no no this is a bar of
soap that i'm still using it's been on
three road trips okay just irish spring
and then when you're done
zip everything up
we're out
[Music]
this is an important conversation we
need to have let's talk about body hair
a lot of men with melanin we have dark
body hair so it's important when you get
to your hotel room i bring a beer
trimmer
and also a body trimmer
this is the beard trimmer the phillips
norelco beard trimmer you can adjust the
height of your beard it's really clutch
what you see right here on me right now
is a 1.5 or a 2. and this is the
manscaped and i just like to keep it
super tight you know what i mean now you
may be asking why don't you do both
trimmings at home i am married and i
have my wife and we share a bathroom i
like to treat hotel bathrooms the same
way the united states treats its foreign
policy i'ma get up in there i'ma make a
mess
and then i'm gonna walk out and act like
it was never my fault this is laquinta
inn's problem
everybody has asked me what do you put
in your hair at patriot act i used to
say coconut oil and prayer this is what
i actually put in my hair i'll start
with
a grooming tonic like this i don't know
if i'm pronouncing this correctly this
is the ruselle it kind of has the like
that thick coconut oil type feel i'll
let that sit for a little bit i'll blow
dry it and then i'll put a little bit of
baxter's clay pomade in there i'm damn
near empty and i'm just waiting for
another makeup department to come in
and make it happen i have very thick
coarse black hair so i use something
like this i think this is a horse brush
i don't know what but it's very coarse
but it lets me keep the cowlicks down
and we're good and once again this is
not mine this was part of the makeup
department
[Music]
oh look at that catch this is one of my
favorite brands right now in terms of
shirts i was actually wearing these on
stage this past weekend so if i'm doing
like eight shows in a weekend what i'll
do is i'll just keep a bunch backstage
and then i'll just rotate through them
the worst thing is if you ever watch
like videos of comedians in the 90s
they'll have two things they'll have a
towel and sometimes they'll take the
town that's like wipe sweat and i was
like i cannot i cannot go full cedric
the entertainer so what i've been trying
to do is find a shirt that gives you
buttons that makes it feel like it's a
dressed up event because there's a lot
of guys that are either wearing hoodies
or t-shirts on stage and for a theater
audience to come in it's like what are
we doing here let's make this feel like
this is a professional setting it's a
camp collar shirt by uh saturday's new
york city they have these shirts and i
just bought them in multiple different
colors it's really cool it has this like
little like lining on the inside that
feels like it's like a technical
material but the material is really
great it's not cotton if i sweat in it
it doesn't get that like back circle
so when i turn this way from the
audience where i turn this way they just
see this like
you know to be y equals x squared
yeah you don't want that
this is where everything starts this is
the journal of all the material and
everything that i'm working on yeah i'm
pretty nerdy with it i'll mark it up
workshop and material stories bits
things that i like and then
piece by piece as the act starts to come
together i'm talking to the director of
my show and we're working on the king's
jester we'll just start marking up each
act like all right we need to punch this
up we should move this section here and
then what i like to do is go into google
docs and then i'll just write out the
entire show
and this is the entire show 49 pages
all the way from act one to the end of
the show
and then every night i'm just trying to
improve different sections i'll start
highlighting it and if you're wondering
husson are you using your printer at
home absolutely not i will go into the
hotel
i'll say where's the business center
and can i print and color and sometimes
they'll be like email us the pdf and as
soon as this pdf hits their inbox i'm
like you said it was okay
because the look of vitriol they have in
their eyes that they have to print out a
49-page document in color oh they want
to kill me
all my friends clown me for this i spill
food on myself all the time i don't have
one i have two type ends okay how to
look like an adult even though you might
not be one let's talk about the pen war
fans of the daily show you know that jon
stewart for years rocked with the
classic blue bic i'm gonna be honest
with you the flow of the blue bic
not a fan when you pull it out dead
stock yeah it's great but
like a relationship that's fizzling out
you pick it up day two day three day
four it's not bringing it the way it
used to which is why the uniball vision
elite this pen is amazing what's great
about it is when you put it on the paper
you don't have to push really hard it's
got a great flow it's thick enough to
right quickly it's thin enough to still
not bleed and blotch i will steal a pen
from a hotel this is from the oyster
point hotel from red bank new jersey i
stole it this weekend i was at the front
desk i said hey can i borrow a pen i
didn't borrow it i took it the reason
why i like writing is because it does
lock in an idea the reason why i like
blue specifically is you want separation
and color between black text and then
blue it lets you mark up and move stuff
and then if i'm just doing tags or if
i'm doing additional ideas that i want
to add to reading i'll go with black and
then when bits work
i use these specific sharpies sharpie
highlighters i've noticed that sometimes
sharpies trying to get fancy with it
they'll do a dark blue highlighter a
dark orange and then when you highlight
it it's it's so dark you can't even read
it just give us what's most effective
just go yellow
[Music]
so i was wearing a timex for years and
years and then i jumped into the pool
the todd snyder timex collab timex that
i got for free broke a couple friends
cornered me and they said you're 35
years old you have to stop doing this
you need to get a watch it's funny
enough i was in bindi jewelers and
anyone here who's from the daisy
community knows you would go as a child
to bendy jewelers either in the greater
artesia area
or in the bay area and you would go in
and you would sit in the back and you
would slowly cry as your mom straight up
walks into bendy jewelers and and buys
gold its straight up looks like indiana
jones temple of doom the opening
sequence of aladdin like it's they see
mom's going to buy jewelry for weddings
and or other events so they can flex on
other aunties and you would just sit
there as a kid one day i came of age i
walked into bendy jewelers and as soon
as i walked in they said where's your
mom and i said don't worry about it
simba has come back to pride rock
to buy his own piece i bought this omega
speedmaster i always was a fan omega
specifically from the first james bond
movie that i watched with my dad which
was the pierce bros and gold knight and
he was wearing the seamaster in it and
if you remember at the time fossil ended
up ripping off that watch and that was
one of the hottest watches in eighth
grade so i had a blue fossil that looked
like the omega sea master and so before
i walked into bendy jewelers i told my
wife bina i was like what if i get the
sea master and you get the constellation
and she goes no i don't want that and so
the second best choice to me was the
speedy it's the moon watch i like the
new one the vintage ones kind of feel
lighter i wanted it to feel heavier and
and kind of beefier and and i'm really
happy with this so shout out to bendy
jewelers i am an adult now this is the
apple watch i
have to set an alarm early in the
morning my wife sleeps next to me and i
used to have one of those old school
alarms that would go off and go
4 30 a.m get to laguardia and bina's
like stop so i actually got this not for
any other technology but to just have
like a beeping vibrator on my wrist it
just beeps it vibrates i'm up it doesn't
wake her up
and i'm off to the airport so it's just
for that
[Music]
when you're traveling what i like to do
is keep three pairs of shoes i have two
for stage
and alternate and then a gym shoe the
gym shoe doubles for two things you get
to wear this in the airport
and you can wear it to the gym shout out
to kobe this is the kobe 5 pro tro great
gym shoe it's low cut it looks like it's
a running shoe it's a basketball shoe
keep your gym socks inside of them these
are stance mba socks that i stole from
the nba all-star game you need two-stage
shoes i like a high-top i like a low top
this is the nike air force one john
elliott i think they're really cool just
the laces on them they have this
metallic lace on it they look really
great the way they stacked the tongue is
really cool so it kind of creates the
separation just these little details i
thought were really nice and the leather
is beautiful some of you guys in the
comments might be mad at me oh you need
to keep them crispy white i'm not dame
dash i don't just buy a hundred pairs of
air force ones at a time i don't know
who you think i am i drive a honda
odyssey this to me is the shoe of the
year the air jordan 3 amman manier
they're my favorite shoe air jordan 3 is
one of my favorite shoes the quality on
these is so cool i really love hairy
suede this is the era of hairy suede
they're keeping that suede really hairy
these days guys no elephant print
they're going full hairy suede y'all and
what i like to do is when you want to
keep that toe box crisp what i do is i
take a a pair of socks
from winter 8th grade
and put them in there look at these
these are thick socks from old navy
and just just put them in and then what
you do in the heel is i put the other
the regular socks i'm unstuck kissing
everybody else look i can only take so
many disappointments in life i don't
even mess with the sneakers app anymore
i'm gonna go to stockx i'm gonna pay the
premium and keep it moving
thank you for hanging out and thank you
for watching my essentials